this documentation you mentioned you see
the one in charge he gets you to stop
uggs and offer them this opportunity to
do business with her go see for yourself
my friend has documents to pass
checkpoints to keep a lease of your bank
to get into parts of Prague you never
knew existed tell him DRA whom you sent
you you'll see I give you address yes
all right give me the address i think
i'd like to see who's behind all this
Jocasta there's a courtier behind the
apartment building very easy to find my
friend will be there he will get you
latest permit care just pay him and
don't ask questions
hope you met your quota today just shut
up
the syrup
Oh
and
his hair is restricted to you what that
one who got out to toppling you looking
for permit I will stop by someone named
ramir at a checkpoint he sent me here
apparently you have bought with
documentation or printed permits you
have the money maybe want something when
I'm paying for exactly you pay to get
your name on the list Molina upstairs
she works on your shiny new permit you
come back in one week to pick it up
standard pickup fee will apply how much
you charge people for this not people
dogs 35 thousand credits
you're not even trying are you you just
played me scam arms up as much as you
can you want updated permit or not
documents are actually pretty good
you'll see trust me the girl is very
talented these documents what are they
stolen forged invisible look just give
me what you have and i'll put your name
on the list that's how it works Molina
does surprisingly good work puts more
effort than them we asked her to
I think I've heard all I need to about
your offer and about your friend
upstairs I'm gonna try my chances with
other papers for now suit yourself only
a matter of time before they come
knocking at night
you're looking for permit not know why I
never get to work a checkpoint
over there we hear that warming with
God's with us there's a bad Bible
there's too many shares in the take
set something in the corner
i'm looking forward to squeezing
I hope you're not at the prod